[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARA ROBINSON: Hi, everyone.
Thank you for coming.
Today we're going to talk
about machine learning APIs
by example.
I'm going to teach
you how you can
access pre-trained
machine learning models
with a single API call.
My name is Sara Robinson.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Cloud Platform
team, which basically means I
get to help build demos, give
talks about them, and
bring product feedback back
to the engineering teams.
You can find me on
Twitter, @SRobTweets.
And I live in New York.
So before we get
started, let's talk
about what machine learning
is at a high level.
So at a high level,
machine learning
is teaching computers
to recognize patterns
in the same way
that our brains do.
So it's really easy for
a child to recognize
the difference between a
picture of a cat and a dog,
but it's much more
difficult to teach computers
to do the same thing, right?
So we could write rules to
look for specific things,
but we can almost always
find a condition that's
going to break those rules.
So instead, what
we want to do is
write code that finds these
rules for us and improves
over time through
examples and experience.
Here we have a
neural network that's
identifying a picture as either
a picture of a cat or a dog.
And we can think of the
input to this network
as pixels in the image.
And then each neuron
is looking for
a specific identifying feature.
Maybe it's the shape
of the ear or the hair.
And then the output
is a prediction--
in this case, that is a dog.
Let's take a step back
from this for a moment
and let's try some
human-powered image detection,
if we were to do
this on our own.
We'll take this picture
of an apple and an orange.
And let's say we
were going to start
writing an algorithm
that would identify
the difference
between these two.
What are some features that
you might look for you?
You can shout it out.
AUDIENCE: Color.
SARA ROBINSON: Color.
I heard a bunch of "color."
AUDIENCE: Shape.
SARA ROBINSON: Shape.
AUDIENCE: Texture.
SARA ROBINSON: Texture--
lots of good ones.
So color's a good
one, but then what
would happen if we had
black and white images?
Then we might have to
start all over again.
So in that case, we
could for a stem.
Texture would be good.
But then what happens
if we add a third fruit?
If we add a mango, we have to
start all over again as well.
But these pictures are
all pretty similar, right?
So what would happen if we had
pictures of two things that
were very different?
This should be
really easy, right?
A dog and a mop have pretty
much nothing in common
from these pictures
that I can see.
But it's actually
a little tricky.
So what we have here is
pictures of sheep dogs and mops.
And it's actually kind of hard
to tell the difference, right?
If we were going to write code
that identified these two,
it would be pretty tricky to do.
And then what happens if we
have photos of everything?
We don't want to
write specific rules
to identify each little thing
that we're trying to look for.
And in addition to photos, we
could have many other types
of unstructured data.
We could have
video, audio, text,
lots of different types of
data we'd be dealing with.
And really, we want
some tools to help
us make sense of all of
this unstructured data.
And Google Cloud Platform
has several products
to help you benefit
from machine learning.
On the left-hand side here,
you can use your own data
to build and train your
own machine learning model.
So we have TensorFlow and Cloud
Machine Learning Engine for you
to do that.
And on the right-hand
side, this is
where I'm going to focus today.
This is what I like to call
friendly machine learning.
These are machine learning
APIs that give you
access to a pre-trained
machine learning model with one
single REST API request.
So you make a request.
You send it some data.
You get some data back from
this pre-trained model.
And you don't have to worry
about building and training
your own model or anything
that's going on under the hood.
I'm going to give
you an introduction
to each of these five APIs.
I'm going to start
with Vision, and I'm
going to end with Video
Intelligence, which
is our newest API you may have
seen in the keynote yesterday.
So let's get
started with Vision.
The Vision API lets you
do complex image detection
with a simple REST request.
And I'm going to
start each section
by talking about a
customer or customers
that are using each API.
So for the Vision API, the
first example on the left
is Disney used the
Vision API for a game
to promote the movie
"Pete's Dragon."
And the way the game worked is
that users were given a quest.
So they had a clue,
and they had to take
a picture of that word--
maybe couch, computer,
everyday objects.
And if they took the
picture correctly,
they would superimpose an image
of the dragon on that object.
So the problem was
they needed a way
to verify that the user took a
picture of the correct object
that they were prompted for.
And the Vision API was a
perfect fit to do that.
They used the label detection
feature, which basically tells
you, what is this a picture of?
And they were able to verify
images in the game that way.
Realtor.com uses the Vision API
for their mobile application.
So its a real estate
listing service, and people
can go around as they
are looking for houses
and take pictures of
a "for sale" sign.
And they use the Vision
API's OCR, Optical Character
Recognition, to read
the text in the image
and then pull up the relevant
listing for that house.
So those are two examples of
the Vision API in production.
Let's talk a little bit more
about the specific features
of the Vision API.
So as I mentioned, we
have label detection,
which is kind of the
core feature which
tells-- you send it an image.
In this case, it's a cheetah.
And it'll tell you what
this is a picture of.
It'll give you a bunch
of different labels back.
Face detection will
identify faces in an image.
It'll tell you where those
faces are in the image.
And it'll even tell you if
they're happy, sad, surprised,
or angry.
OCR is what I mentioned
with realtor.com's use case.
This can identify
text in an image.
It will tell you where the
text is, what the text says,
and what language it's in.
Explicit content
detection will tell you,
is this image
appropriate or not--
really useful if
you've got a site
with a lot of
user-generated content
and you don't want to
manually filter images.
You can use this API method
to do that really easily.
Landmark detection will tell
you, is this a common landmark?
If so, what is the
latitude and longitude?
And then logo detection,
pretty self-explanatory,
will identify logos in an image.
So a quick look at some
of the JSON response
you might get back for
these different features.
This is face detection.
This is actually a selfie
that I took with two teammates
on a trip to Jordan last year.
And the response you're looking
at in the slide is on my face.
So it'll return an
object for each face
you find in the image.
And we can see it says, headwear
likelihood, very unlikely,
which is true.
I'm not wearing a hat.
But for both of my teammates, it
did return headwear likelihood,
very likely.
And then we can see
it's highlighted below.
It says, joy likelihood is
very likely, which is true.
I am smiling in the picture.
The next feature I want to
show you the response for
is landmark detection.
So we have a
picture here of what
looks like the Eiffel Tower.
It's actually the Paris Hotel
and Casino in Las Vegas.
I wanted to see if the
Vision API was fooled.
And it was not.
It correctly identified this
as the Paris Hotel and Casino.
You can see that MID
in the JSON response.
That's an ID that maps to
Google's Knowledge Graph
API, which will just give
you a little more data
about the entity.
And it also tells us the
latitude and longitude of where
this Paris Hotel and Casino is.
In addition to these features,
we launched some new features
this week, which
you may have heard
about in yesterday's keynote.
I'm going to quickly
talk about what they are.
And then I'll show
you some examples.
The first one is
crop hints, which
will give you suggested crop
dimensions for your photos.
Web annotations-- I'm super
excited about this one.
This will give you
some granular data
on entities, web entities
that are found in your image.
It'll also tell you all the
other pages where the image
exists on the internet.
So if you need to do
copyright detection,
it'll give you the URL
of the image and the URL
of the page where the image is.
And then finally, we announced
document text annotations.
So in addition to the OCR we
had before, this is improved
OCR for large blocks of text.
If you have an image of
a receipt or something
with a lot of text,
it'll give you
very granular data on the
paragraphs and the words
and the symbols in that text.
Some examples of
the new features,
I want to highlight
web annotations.
So here we have a
picture of a car.
It's in a museum.
I'm actually a big
"Harry Potter" fan,
so this is a car from one of
the "Harry Potter" movies.
And I wanted to
see what the Vision
API was able to find from the
web entities in this image.
So it was able to
identify it correctly
as a Ford Anglia,
which is correct.
This is from the second
"Harry Potter" movie when they
tried to fly a car to school.
Second entity it returned
is art science museum.
And this is a
museum in Singapore
where this car is on display.
And it is finally
able to tell me
that this car is from
"Harry Potter," which
is a literary series.
So lots of great metadata
you can get back from web
annotations.
Even more data that it returns--
it tells you the full
matching image URLs.
Where else does this image
exists on the internet?
Partial matching images.
And then finally, all the
pages that point to this image.
It's really useful
information you get back
with web annotations.
And you can try this in the
browser with your own images
before writing any code.
Just go to
cloud.google.com/vision.
You can upload your
images, play around,
see all the responses
you get back
from the different features.
And you can actually do
this with all of the APIs
that I'm going to
talk about today.
There's a way to try
them in the browser.
And in case you were wondering
how the Vision API did
with the sheep dogs and mops,
so this is the response it got
from that picture on the right.
So it's 99% sure it's a dog.
It actually even is able to
identify the breed of the dog--
Komondor.
I may be saying that wrong.
And the mops, it
successfully identified this
as a broom or a tool.
And skipping ahead, it
did pretty well overall.
In the top row, the third one,
it didn't identify it as a dog.
It just said "fur."
So I don't know if
that's a hit or a miss.
And then the third
mop, it said "textile."
So it didn't quite get that
it was a mop or a broom.
But overall, Vision API
performed pretty well
on these tricky images that are
even hard for us to decipher
what they are exactly.
So that was the
Vision API showing you
how you can get a lot
of data on your images
with a pre-trained
machine learning model.
Next I want to talk
about audio data.
And the Speech API essentially
exposes the functionality
of "OK, Google" to developers.
It lets you do speech-to-text
transcription in over 80
languages.
One app that's using the
Speech API is called Azar.
And they have
connected 15 million
matches, an app to
find friends and chat.
And they use the Speech
API for all of the messages
that involve audio snippets.
And they're also using
this in combination
with the Cloud
Translation API, which I'm
going to talk about later on.
So there's a lot of
potential use cases
where you could combine
different machine learning APIs
together.
So in cases where the matches
don't speak the same language,
they'll use the Speech API
to transcribe the audio
and then the Translation
API to translate that text.
The best way to experience
a Speech API is with a demo.
Before I get into it, I want
to explain a bit how it works.
So we're going to
make a recording.
I wrote a bash script.
We're going to use
SoX to do that.
It's a command line
utility for audio.
So what we'll do is
we'll record our audio.
We'll create an API
request in a JSON file.
And we'll send it
to the Speech API.
And then we'll see
the JSON response.
So if we could go ahead
and switch to the demo--
OK, let me make the
font a little bigger.
So I'm going to call my
file with bash request.sh.
And it press "Press Enter
when you're ready to record."
It's going to ask me to record
a five-second audio file.
So here we go.
I built a Cloud Speech
API demo using SoX.
OK, so this is the JSON request
file that it just created.
We need to tell the Speech
API the encoding type.
In this case, we're
using FLAC encoding,
the sample rate in hertz.
The language code is optional.
If you leave it out, it
will default to English.
Otherwise, you need to tell it
what language your audio is in.
And then the speech
context, I'm going
to talk about that
in a little bit.
So I'm going to
call the Speech API.
It's making a curl request.
And let's see how it did.
OK, so it did pretty good.
It said, "I built a Cloud
Speech API demo using socks."
But you'll notice it
got the wrong "SoX"
because "SoX" is a proper noun.
It was 89% confident
that it got this correct.
That even was able to
get "API" as an acronym.
So I mentioned this speech
context parameter before.
And what this actually
lets you do is let's
say you have a
proper noun or a word
that you're expecting
your application that's
unique that you wouldn't expect
the API to recognize normally.
You can actually pass
it as a parameter,
and it'll look
out for that word.
So I'm going to hop
on over to Sublime,
and I'm going to add "SoX"
as a phrase so look out for.
And let's see if it's
able to identify it.
I'm going to say the
same thing again.
I'm going to record.
I built a Cloud Speech
API demo using SoX.
And we can see it's now
got that phrase in there.
And we will call the Speech API.
And it was able to
get it correctly
using the phrases parameter,
which is pretty cool.
Just one REST API
request, and we are easily
transcribing an audio file,
even with a unique entity.
And you can also pass
the API audio files
in over 80 different languages.
You just need to tell it, again,
the language code that you'd
like it to transcribe.
So that is the Speech API.
You can hop back to the slides.
So we've just
transcribed our audio.
We have text.
So what happens if you want to
do more analysis on that text?
And that is where the Natural
Language API comes into play.
It lets you extract entities,
sentiment, and syntax
from text.
A company that's using
the Natural Language API
is called Wootric.
And they are a customer
feedback platform
to help businesses improve
their customer service.
And they do this by collecting
millions of survey responses
each week.
A little more detail
on how it works
is if you look at that
box in the top right--
so a customer would place
this on different pages
throughout their app.
Maybe if you're a
developer, you would see it
on a documentation page.
And it would ask you to rate
your experience on that page
from 0 to 10, which is what
we call the Net Promoter
Score, NPS.
So they gather that
score, and then they
give you some open
feedback to expand on what
you thought of the experience.
So as you can imagine,
it's pretty easy for them
to average out the Net
Promoter Score among tons
of different responses.
But what's much more
difficult is looking
at that open-ended feedback.
And that's where they use
the Natural Language API.
And they actually made
use of all three methods
in the Natural Language API.
They used intimate analysis to
calibrate the numbered score
that users gave with their
feedback to see if it aligned.
And then they use the entity and
syntax annotation to figure out
what the subject
was of the feedback
and then route it accordingly.
So maybe somebody was
unhappy about pricing.
Then they could
route that feedback
to the necessary person
and respond pretty fast.
So using the Natural
Language API,
they were able to route
and respond to feedback
in near real-time
rather than having
someone need to
read each response,
classify it, and then route it.
So let's look at each of the
methods of the Natural Language
API in a bit more detail.
As I mentioned, I'm a
big "Harry Potter" fan.
So I took this sentence from
JK Rowling's Wikipedia page.
And let's see what happens
if we send this to the entity
extraction endpoint.
So it's able to pull these five
entities from the sentence.
And the JSON we get
back looks like this.
So what's interesting
here is JK Rowling's name
is written in three
different ways.
Robert Galbraith is
actually a pen name
she used for a
later book series.
And it's able to point all
of these to the same entity.
So if you had things like
"San Francisco" and "SF,"
it would point those
to the same entities
so that you could count the
different ways of mentioning
the same thing as
the same entity.
So we can see it finds her
name, Joanne "Jo" Rowling.
It tells you what
type of entity it is--
a person.
And then if the
entity has metadata,
it'll give you more
metadata about it.
So here we get an MID, which
maps to JK Rowling's Knowledge
Graph entry.
And then we get the Wikipedia
URL to the page about her.
The JSON response look
similar for the other entities
we found--
British.
It maps it to a location.
And then notice it connects it
to the United Kingdom Wikipedia
URL.
So if it had instead said
"UK" or "United Kingdom,"
it would point it
to the same page.
And then for "Harry
Potter," we also get person.
And we get the Wikipedia
page for that entity as well.
So that's entity extraction.
That's one method you could use
in the Natural Language API.
The next one is
sentiment analysis.
So this is a review
you might see.
It says, "The food
was excellent,
I would definitely go back."
And we get two things here.
We get a score value,
which will tell us,
is the sentiment
positive or negative?
It's a value ranging
from negative 1 to 1.
So we can see here it's
almost completely positive.
And then magnitude
will tell you how
strong is the sentiment
regardless of being
positive or negative.
This can range
from 0 to infinity.
And it's based on the
length of the text.
So since this is a pretty
short block of text,
the value is pretty low.
And then finally, you
can analyze syntax.
So this method is
a bit more complex.
It gets into the linguistic
details of a piece of text.
It returns a bunch of
different data here.
This visualization
is actually created
from the in-browser demo.
So if you want to try
it out in the browser,
you can create a
similar visualization
with your own text.
And what it returns is on that
top row, those green arrows,
that's what we call a
dependency parse tree.
And that will tell us how each
of the words in a sentence
relate to each other,
which words they depend on.
In the second row, we
see the orange row.
That's the parse
label, which tells us
the role of each
word in the sentence.
So we can see that
"helps"-- the sentence
is "The natural language API
helps us understand text."
"Helps" is the root verb.
"Us" is the nominal subject.
We can see the role of all the
other words in the sentence
as well.
That third row where we only
have one word is the lemma.
We can see here it says "help."
And what that is is the
canonical form of the word.
So the canonical form
of "helps" is "help."
So this way, if
you're trying to count
how many times a
specific word occurs,
it won't count "helps" and
"help" as two different words.
It'll consolidate
them into one word.
And then in red, we
have the part of speech,
whether it's a noun, verb,
adjective, or punctuation.
And then in blue, we have some
additional morphology details
on the word.
There's more of these returned
for Spanish and Japanese,
which are the other two
languages that the API
currently supports.
So the syntax
annotation feature might
be a little harder to
grasp when you might
use this in an application.
So I wanted to show you a
demo specifically focused
on that feature.
And for this demo, over the
course of the past few days--
oh, I think the--
there we go.
Mic is back.
I've been using the
Twitter Streaming API
to stream tweet
about Google Next.
So I've streamed tweets with
the hashtag #googlenext17
and a couple other search terms
that are put in node server
that's running on
Compute Engine.
And I'm streaming those tweets.
So the Streaming API
gathers just a subset
of those tweets, not all the
tweets with that hashtag.
And I'm sending the
text of the tweet
to the Natural Language API.
And then I'm storing the
response in BigQuery.
BigQuery's our big data
analytics warehouse tool.
It let's you do analytics
on really large data sets.
So I'm storing it in BigQuery.
And then from there,
I can gather some data
on the parts of
speech in a sentence.
So I can find, for example,
the most common adjectives
that people are using to
tweet about Google Next.
So if we could go to the demo--
cool.
So this is the BigQuery web
UI which lets you run queries
directly in the browser.
So here, I just did a
limit 10 to show you
what the table looks like.
I think I've got about 6,000
to 7,000 tweets in here so far.
So here I'm collecting the
ID of the tweet, the text,
the created at, how many
followers the user has,
what hashtags it finds that's
returned from the Twitter API.
And then I've got this giant
JSON sring of the response
from the Natural Language API.
So you're probably
wondering, how
am I going to write a
SQL query to parse that?
Well, BigQuery has a feature
called user-defined functions,
which lets you write custom
JavaScript functions that you
can run on rows in your table.
So over here, I've
got a query that's
going to run on every
tweet in this table.
And my JavaScript
function is right here.
And what it's
going to do is it's
going to count all
of the adjectives
and then return that
in my output table.
So if I run this
query here, it's
running this custom
JavaScript function
on all the tweets
in my table, which I
think is about 6,000 right now.
It ran pretty fast, and I'm
not using cached results.
So let's take a look.
We've got 405 uses of the
word "more," "new," "great,"
"good," "late," "awesome."
You can see some more here.
So that's one example of a use
case for the syntax annotation
feature of the
Natural Language API.
You can go back to the slides.
So the Natural Language API
lets you do analysis on text.
One other thing that you
might want to do with text
is translate it.
You likely have users of your
application all over the world.
It'd be useful to translate
it into their host language.
And the Translation API
exposes the functionality
of Google Translate
to developers
and lets you translate
text in 100-plus languages.
And for a second, let's
talk about Google Translate.
I'm a big fan of
Google Translate.
Has anyone here used it before?
It looks like a lot of people.
I use it when I
travel all the time.
So a couple of months ago,
I was on a trip to Japan.
I was at a restaurant
where nobody spoke English,
and I really wanted
to order octopus.
So I typed it into
Google translate.
It turns out the word
for that is "tako,"
which confused me a little bit.
I didn't to order
an octopus taco,
although maybe
that would be good.
So I just showed the
person at the restaurant
my Google translate app,
successfully got my octopus.
That's a picture
of it right there.
But likely, you want to do
more than translate the word
for octopus.
And that's why we have
the Translation API, which
lets you translate text
in your application
in many different languages.
And Airbnb is an example
of a company that's
using the Translation API.
And what you might not know
is that 60% of Airbnb bookings
connects people that are using
the app in different languages
because people use Airbnb a
lot, especially when they travel
internationally.
And so for all of
those connections,
they're using to translate API
to translate not only listings,
but also reviews
and conversations
into the person's
host's language.
And they found that
this significantly
improves a guest
likelihood to book
if it's translated into
their host language.
And that's one example of
someone using the Translation
API.
It's pretty
self-explanatory, but I
wanted to show you a code
snippet of how easy it
is to call the API.
This is some Python code
that's making a request
to the Translation API.
And you can see here we just
create a translate client.
And then we pass it the
phrase we'd like to translate,
the target language.
It'll detect the
original language for us.
And then we can
print the result.
And one thing we've added
to the Translation API
recently is neural
machine translation.
And this greatly improves the
underlying translation model.
And basically, the
way it works is
with first-generation
translation,
which is what we had
before, it was translating
each word in a
sentence separately.
So let's say you
had a dictionary
and you were looking
up word for word
each sentence in the
dictionary and translating it
without understanding the
context around that word, that
works pretty well.
But what neural machine
translation does
is it actually looks at
the surrounding words,
and it's able to
understand the context
of the word in the sentence.
And it's able to produce much
higher quality translations.
There's a great "New York Times"
article with a lot more details
on how that model works.
You can find it at
that Bitly link there.
If anyone wants
to take a picture,
I'll leave it up for a second.
And just to show you
some of the improvements
that neural machine
translation brings--
this is a lot of text.
I know.
But what I did is
I took a paragraph
from the Spanish version
of "Harry Potter."
So this is the original text
that the Spanish translator
wrote.
And then I showed you in
first-generation translation
in the middle how
it'll translate that
to English, and then in
neural machine translation all
the way on the right-hand side.
And I bolded the improvements.
So we can look at a few of them.
The first bold word is--
it says, "which made drills."
It's describing the
company where he works.
And then neural
machine translation
is able to change that
word to "manufactured,"
which is much more specific to
the context of the sentence.
Another example is
if we look at where
it's describing
Mrs. Dursley's neck,
the first generation
says "almost twice longer
than usual."
In the second version, it
says "almost twice as long as
usual," which is a
slight improvement.
And then if we
look at the bottom,
it goes from "fence of the
garden" to "garden fence."
And then in the last
example, the first generation
used the pronoun "their."
And then neural
machine translation
is able to identify the
correct pronoun "her"
more specifically.
So just a quick example
highlighting some improvements
that neural machine translation
brings to the Translation API.
And on its own, the Translation
API is pretty self-explanatory,
but I wanted to show you a
small demo of a Python script
I wrote of how to combine
different APIs together.
So in this demo, it'll take
three types of text input.
It could take either raw text,
audio, or an image of text.
And then we'll pass it through
the Natural Language API.
And then finally,
we'll translate it
into a few languages.
And then we'll translate
it back to English
so that you can see the result.
So if we could switch
back to the demo--
it looks like it's up here.
So I'm going to run the script--
python textify.py.
And it's going to
tell me we're going
to send some text to the
Natural Language API.
It supports English,
Spanish, and Japanese.
And I have three options.
I can either type my
text, record a file,
or send a photo of text.
So I'm going to type some text.
I'm going to say "We are
using the Translation API.
It is awesome."
And we got a bunch
of data back here.
So this is what
the JSON response
looks like just for one token.
I didn't want to print
the whole JSON blob here.
This is just for the token "we."
This is all the
data it returned.
So it tells us it's a pronoun.
And a lot of these part
of speech morphology data
is going to be
unknown for English,
but it relates to
other languages
that the API supports.
But it is able to tell us
that it is a plural token
and it is in first person.
And it is the nominal
subject of the sentence.
And we ran some
sentiment analysis on it.
It says you seem very happy.
It was an excited sentence.
And it tells us the
entities it found.
So it found Translation API.
And the way the entity
analysis endpoint works
is it's able to identify
entities even if they
don't have a Wikipedia URL.
So Translation API
doesn't, but it's still
able to pull this
out as an entity.
So if we were, for example,
building an app to maybe route
customer feedback, we could
say, OK, this feedback
is asking about the
Translation API.
And then we could route it
to the appropriate person.
So now we're going to
translate this text.
And let's translate
it into Japanese.
There we go.
So this is the version
translated into Japanese.
I'm guessing most of us
don't speak Japanese,
so I've translated
it back to English.
And you can see that it
did a pretty good job.
So I'm going to run
the script once more.
And [AUDIO OUT] use an image.
So if we look over here, I've
got just a generic resume
image.
We're going to
pass it to the API.
So I'll clear the screen
and run the text again.
We're going to send
a photo this time.
And it is resume.jpg.
Sending it to the Vision API.
And the Vision API
found, if we scroll up,
all this text in the image.
Using the new document
text extraction,
it was able to pull essentially
all the text from that resume.
There's an example of
what a token returned.
And it found all these
different entities.
And now we can translate it.
Let's translate it to German.
It's a lot of text
there; I know.
But this is the resume
translated into German,
and then again back to English.
So just an example of how you
can combine multiple machine
learning APIs to do
some cool text analysis.
And you can go back
to the slides now.
So that was the Translation API.
And the last thing
I want to talk about
is the Video Intelligence API.
How many of you saw it
at the keynote yesterday?
Looks like most of you.
So the Video
Intelligence API lets
you understand your videos
entities at a shot, frame,
or video level.
So video level entities,
it will tell you,
at a high level, what
is this video about?
And then it'll give
you more granular data
on what is happening in
each scene of the video.
A company that's
using this is Cantemo.
They're a media asset
management company.
So a company or a user
that has a lot of videos
would upload their
videos to Cantemo,
and Cantemo would help them
better understand those videos,
search their library,
transcode videos.
And this is a quote from the
VP of product development
at Cantemo.
He says, "Thanks to the Google
Cloud Video Intelligence API,
we've been able to very
quickly process and understand
the content of video down
to the individual frame
with an impressively
rich taxonomy."
So they're using the
Video API to help
their customers better search
their own video libraries.
And I'm going to show you
the same demo that you
saw in the keynote, but we'll
look at a different video
and go into a bit more detail.
So if we could switch back
to the demo, here's the API.
And I've got a
different video than I
showed in the keynote earlier.
This is a video that just shows
you a tour of the Google Paris
office and a little bit of
the neighborhood around it.
And I'll play the
first bit of it.
It starts up by just
showing some frames.
And then we'll get into a
tour of the neighborhood
around the office.
And then we go inside.
It interviews some employees.
I won't play the whole thing.
But we can look at some
of the labels it returned.
So it's able to identify this
amusement ride, amusement park,
from the beginning.
We know there's a bunch
of very short frames
in the beginning of that video.
It's able to see
that it's a statue.
If we look at the
fruit annotation,
it identifies a basket
of fruit in this scene.
We can scroll down and look
at a couple more labels--
landscaping and cuisine.
We see people getting some food.
And school-- here it thinks
it's a school inside there.
So you can see we're able to get
pretty granular data on what's
happening in each
scene of the video.
And another thing the Video
Intelligence API lets us do
is search a large video library.
So if we're a media
publisher, we've
got petabytes of video data
sitting in storage buckets.
It's otherwise pretty hard
to search a large library
of video content.
You'd have to manually
watch the videos looking
for a particular clip if
you want to create, say,
like a highlight reel
of a specific content
within your library.
Intelligence API makes
this pretty easy,
because as you can see, all the
data we get back on this video,
we can get that back on all the
videos in our library, which
makes it pretty easy to just
search for a specific entity
within our library.
So as I showed you
in the keynote,
one example is let's say--
actually, first, let me
show you the library.
So we've got a bunch of
videos here, as you can see.
And let's say we'd like to
search for all our baseball
videos.
We can see what
we get back here.
And it shows us this video is
almost entirely about baseball.
This one has fewer
baseball clips.
And we can point to all
of them specifically.
And then in this one, we
see that moment from the--
not playing.
Let me try refreshing the page.
There we go.
We see that moment from the Year
in Search video from last year
when the Cubs won
the World Series.
I'm from Chicago, so I was
pretty excited about that.
One more search that I
showed you before is we
can find all of the beach
clips in our videos.
So here, it's easy to, if we
wanted to create a highlight
reel, if we were really
missing the beach,
see all the beach
clips in our videos.
It'd be super easy to do this
using the Video Intelligence
API.
Now, since most of you saw
this demo in the keynote,
I wanted to talk a little bit
more about how I built it.
So you can go back to slides.
It was built by
me and Alex Wolfe.
If you like the UI, you should
give him a shoutout on Twitter,
@alexwolfe.
He would appreciate it.
So we worked on this together.
And this is an architecture
diagram of how it works.
So the video API processing
is being done on the back end.
And the way it works is you
pass the Video Intelligence
API a Google Cloud
Storage URL of your video.
And then it'll run the
analysis on that video.
So I have a Cloud
Storage bucket where
I'm storing all my videos.
And I've got a cloud function
listening on that bucket.
And that cloud function
will be triggered
anytime a new file is
added to the bucket.
It will check if it's a video.
If it is, it'll send it
to the Video Intelligence
API for processing.
And one cool thing
about the API is
you can pass it the output
URL of the URL of a file
you'd like it to write
the JSON response to
in Google Cloud Storage.
So I've got a
separate cloud storage
bucket where I'm storing all
the video annotation JSON
responses.
And the API automatically writes
all of my video annotations
to that bucket.
So the front end
of my application
doesn't have to call
the video API directly.
It's already got all that
metadata in two separate cloud
storage buckets.
And the front end
of the application
is a Node.js application
built on Google App Engine.
That's a little bit
about how the demo works.
And this is more
granularly what the JSON
response looks like from
the Video Intelligence API.
So this is a video of a
tour of the White House.
And at this particular
point in time,
it identifies the label
"Bird's-eye view."
And it's able to tell us
the start time and end
time in microseconds of
where that label appears
in the video.
And it also returns a confidence
score ranging from 0 to 1,
which will tell us how confident
is the API that it successfully
identified this as
bird's-eye view.
In this case, it is 96%.
So it is pretty confident that
this is a bird's-eye view.
And then one more
snippet of this video,
a portrait of George
Washington-- and it's
able to successfully identify
that this is a portrait.
It tells us the
start time and end
time of where that is in the
video, along with a confidence
score--
83%.
So just an example of
what the JSON looks
like that you get back from
the Video Intelligence API.
That wraps up my
tour of the APIs.
And if you all want to
start using them today,
you can go to the try-it pages.
So for each of the
API product pages,
as I showed you
with Vision, there's
an in-browser demo where you can
try out all the APIs directly
in the browser before
writing any code
to see if it's right for
you and your application.
So I definitely recommend
checking that out.
I'll let you guys take a picture
of that page before I switch.
OK, it looks like almost
everyone has got it.
Some other talks that
I recommend that are
related to machine learning--
BigQuery and Cloud
Machine Learning Engine
was a talk that was yesterday.
All the videos from yesterday
have already been posted.
So if there's any talks that you
wanted to see that you missed,
you can go watch
them on YouTube.
Another talk, Introduction
to Video Intelligence--
so if you want to see a
deep-dive on the Video
Intelligence API,
[INAUDIBLE], who's
the product manager on that,
is going to be giving that talk
today at 4:00 PM.
Highly recommend
checking that talk out.
And then if you're more
interested in the side
of building and training your
own machine learning model,
there's a session
tomorrow at 11:20
on the lifecycle of a
machine learning model.
I definitely recommend
checking out all three
of these sessions.
And if you can't make
it, you can always
watch the videos on
YouTube after the session.
So thank you.
That's all I've got.
[APPLAUSE]